il s'agit pas en réalité de lutter
contre les sectes dangereuses pour
l'ordre public ou pour les individus
mais instrumentaliser cette souffrance
en fabriquant de l'unanimisme politique
en réalité il y à montréal il ya trois
dimensions qui sont bel et la première
dimension c'est que sont ces sectes qui
serait suppose être dangereuse pour le
public en général ce sont ce que les
sociologues appellent des et des maires
des nouveaux mouvements religieux qui
sont étudiées par papa par les
sociologues dans le monde entier on
étudie ces nouveaux mouvements et ses
mouvements les seuils de comprendre
cliniquement on essaie de comprendre
sociologiquement économiquement d'où il
vient et c'est il ya des ethnographes
qui les études libres
ça c'est une première chose dont on
aurait utilisé ses travaux ce qu'on ne
fait pas en réalité un deuxième si on
voulait vraiment comprendre ce qui se
passe deuxième point il à
l'instrumentalisation politique qui
court circuite en réalité la lutte
contre les sectes qui serait vraiment
dangereuse et et le troisième point c
est ce qu on pourrait mettre une
quelle pourrait être la lutte efficace
moi j'ai proposé quelque chose avait
proposé quelque chose les faits un
arctique même dans le monde en 2008 sur
ce sujet qui avait fait beaucoup parler
ou je proposais de d'essayer de monter
un système qui ressemble un peu à ce qui
existe au royaume uni est une forme qui
est à à la london school of economics of
economic pardon qu'est ce qu'ils font
dans cette donne c'est très simple il
met des représentants des familles et
donc des victimes des associations de
victimes dont on les exclut pas leçon là
il explique qu'elle est leur souffrance
pourquoi étaient ils à elle souffre deux
des chercheurs et des sociologues qui
discute avec avec eux qui font
participer leurs recherches à cela et
des représentants aussi de l'état et 6
mai et là on aurait une vision beaucoup
plus réalistes concrètes qui ne mettrait
pas à ce boisseau le les victimes et qui
en même temps relativiserait leurs
propos et on serait capable de lutter de
façon efficace mais l'état français ne
veut pas ça il ne veut pas mettre ce
système en place parce que il ce prix
vrai de cette source d'
instrumentalisation politique incroyable
[Musique]